>> Okay, cool. So we're back, I've seen this
before. We've made an object, this is good. we
have all these things, again, standard fields, custom fields,
what are these guys. Related lookup validation, all that.
>> So these are different things that we can build, mainly
business logic, around our attendee object. And so we'll go into more
of what this is later, but we'll be able to create
validation rules for making sure that we input good data, page layouts
for being able to modify how that form looks when we create a record. All
these different layouts, I mean, this is really
your one-stop shop for modifying your attendee object.
>> Okay.
>> And at the very top, boom.
>> Oh yeah, we've got our tab. All right.
Cool. So we want to add a field, right?
>> Yes, let's add some fields.